So if you look at the redo log, it has
a transaction header, and in between the transaction header and
end mark are all the changes that have been made
in that particular critical section by the developer. And for
each of the address changed within that critical section, what
is the new data that corresponds to the changes that
have been made to that page? Similarly what is the
new data for this range, new data for this range.
That's the structure of this redo log record that
has been created and forced to the disk. Now,
when we resume from the crash, what we need
to do is make sure that the external data
segments Are updated with all the changes that have
been made and recorded in the redo log but
have not yet been applied to the external data
segments. So crash recovery is of course the whole reason
for LRVM. And what we're going to do when we resume from crash is read the
redo log starting from the tail Of the
entire log segment, and that's where the reverse
displacements come into play. And once you've read
the log from the disk, apply to the
external data segments where it has to go
to. All of that information is contained in
the redo log record in terms of the
transaction. What is the address range that is being
modified? What is the external data segment that
particular address range corresponds to? All that information is
contained in the redo log record. So you
can take that and apply to the external data
segment. And once you've done that, you can throw
away the log. So that's how Crash Recovery works.